my first experience was using a massager  a classic I used my grandma's uh  vibrating neck pillow thing that she had  I [ __ ] nut it all over that [ __ ]  you've probably seen it it looks like a  scarf thing where you kind of like yeah  yeah you connect it and then like  there's a button and then the back goes  like that right I used to just play with  it on my shoulder and all that and then  one day it found its way on my dick yeah  yeah  that's [ __ ] bomb what the hell is  this I was so addicted to using that  thing I [ __ ] smothered it with so  much like pre-cum covered in pre-cum did  you ever see your grandmother use it  afterwards yeah but I don't know if they  knew it looked like Snot was all over  that [ __ ] how did you feel seeing your  grandma have your [ __ ] pre-cum on her  neck dude I was so impulsive I don't  remember [ __ ] I just remember oh that's  my that's my toy right there  that's my dog